Yle Areena.
Tiliote siinä hakemuksen liitteen.
No minähän lähetisen sitten sen minun tiliotteen siinä,
tai siis teisen hakemuksen siinä omakelassa,
ja kaikki meni hienosti,
ja lopuksi sitten, ku kaiken piti olla valmista,
niin tää kone ilmoittaa sitten tietomakone,
että tota liitteitä ei tarvita.
No, minä nyt kuitenkin sitten soitiin sinne Kelan numeroon,
mikä oli siinä kirjeessä,
sinne meni 15 minuuttia odottaessa,
Sit sieltä vastasi joku, kerroin asiani,
niin sen jälkeen oli neljä minuuttia hiljaista,
ja painettiin linja poikki.
Ei Piru viäk.
No, sitten otin yhteyttä siellä omakelassa,
sieltä chattipuolelta, 25 minuuttia sai odottaa sinne,
että pääsi tota, teen asiakaspalvelijan kanssa keskustelee,
ja hän viis minuuttia sitten tarkisti sitä,
että tarvitaanko sitä Pirun tiliotetta,
vai eikö sitä tarvitaan.
No, sitten se sanoi, että ei sitä nyt vielä tiedä,
että odottelet vaan sitten soittoa,
että jos tarvitaan,
että virkailija soittaa sulle sitten jos.
No, Piru viäköön, minä mitään semmosia jääny odotteleen,
että laituin sitten suoraan sentään,
ku siellä se viestipalvelu onni,
erillisviesti,
ja sitten sen Pirun edellisen kuun tiliotteen.
Kyllä tää semmoista pompottelua,
ja pahitahan tässä hommassa on se,
ettei se pelkkä ajan meida.
Nutta ku siihen meni rahoakin,
ku se ei kuulu mihkään puhepakettii,
se Kelan numero, Piru viäköön.
Et on tää, kyllä semmoista kansalaisten kusettamista,
että, kyllä se apettaa.
Hyvää kesäjatkoa kuitenkin kaikille.
Joskus joissain paikoissa asioinnin jälkeen
ihmistä pyydetään antamaan palautetta,
että kuinka se asiointi oikein sujui.
Hyvähän se on,
kertoa ne onnistumiset ja epäonnistumiset
asiakkaan näkökulmasta,
niin voidaan sitten mahdollisuuksien mukaan
tehdä tarvittavia korjauksia.
Se on kansanradio ja Lasse Olkinoira tässä tervehdys,
ja jos puolituntisen aikana halutaan banaanikärpäsistä eroon,
puolustetaan sysmänteiden kuntoa,
ja ollaan hyvin huolissaan siitä,
että mihin suuntaan koko Suomi on nyt matkalla,
niin kansanradioltahan tuo vähän kuulostaa.
Aina ei viikon uutisoiduin asia ole,
meidän vastaajassa se kommentoiduin asia,
mutta kyllä se tällä viikolla sitä oli.
Hallihankesen, rahoitus, hallituksen luottamus
ja kesälomansa hetkeksi keskeyttäneet kansan edustajat,
niistä aiheesta puhelua tuli erityisen paljon.
Kyllä oli taas oikea teatteriesitys tuo eduskunnan homma.
En kyllä ymmärrä perkelehtä, ku tullaan totisella naamalla valehtelemaan,
jotta ei mitään oo väärää tehty.
Ja justiin on jäänyt kiinni koko porukka.
Mun mielestä pitääs kaikki laittaa pellolle sieltä,
ja virkamies hallitus.
Tämä on aivan menny lekkeripeliksi tämä koko eduskunnan.
Haukotaha, ja riirellähän kaiket aikaa,
ja kaikki asiat jää oitamatta.
Virkamies hallitus vaan, siellä numerot kertoo,
jotta mitä tehdään.
Ei tarttia valehdella eikä juokalehtaa kenenkään.
Menkään kotia, koko porukka sieltä,
mä en ainakaan enää pitkään maksa tuota touhua,
jos se tuolaisena säilyy. Kiitos.
No joo, mitehä siinä nuin kävi?
Ko tuo suhmura, Santra, alaiko suhmuroimaan tuolla eduskunnassa,
niin piti kesää lomalla kilätä kaikkien töihin.
Se on vissiin nyt paras säästöteko.
Nii sanotut säästäjät ajelee ja lentelee kesälomiltaan karveistuntoa.
Paljonkohan nyt tuli säästöjä?
Ja kenen tilistä se opettaa?
Ei muuta ku laittakaa hampaat naulaan,
ei niille ole enää käyttöä.
Pohjoissa voistatuta kuuskympinää ja ihmettelee villan tuon veronmaksajat,
maksakunnaa kansanäytösijat tulloo sinne kokkoksiin,
eikö ne voilti?
Siltä netin katta pitä se, iänestykset, eipä tieltä muuta.
Eku, heippa.
Hyvää iltaa.
Vapaavuodelle vaan sellaiset terveisetestä.
Puhut sinääni, minä pitelen hevosta, kiitos.
Jussi Etelvoimaalta.
Onko suomalaiset ansainneet tällaisen hallituksen Suomeen,
mikä nytkin näyttää vallalla olevan,
että Helsinki-keskeistä politiikkaa ajataan tuoli pakolla,
ja oikeastaan pakolla läpitti,
eikö ole minkään moista selkärankaa Suomen kansalla.
Kyllä Kekkonenkin jo olis puhaltanut aikaa, jo pelin poikki.
Kansalle pitäis antaa jotakin muutakin kuin keppiä.
Kylä porkkanaakin tartis joskus,
ja ehkä mustikoita ja mansikoitakin,
mutta ei tällä mennolla näytä Suomen hallitossa tulevan mitää,
mitää apuja kansalle.
On jotakin muutakin kuin Helsinki.
Kiitos paljon.
Pessimisti, tässä hyvät päivät.
Onko Suomessa ollut semmoista hallitusta,
jossa ei oo ilimennyt tämmöstä milunkin peliä,
ja tämmöstä vaalirahoittajia hommaa,
että se on kulkaa nii, että pessimisti ei petty.
Viikon aikana, näin kansanradion kuulokulmasta,
moni muukin aihe ihmetyttänyt moneen muuhun aiheeseen vaadittu vastauksia,
tai ehkä kohteliaasti pyydetty vastauksia.
Vielä kumminkin hetkeksi palataan eduskuntaan,
harmistunut kansalainen kysyy,
että miksi siellä eduskunnassa saa käyttää kännykkää täysistunnon aikana.
Työpaikalla ei saa käyttää omaa kännykkää työaikana,
kouluissa kännykät kerätään pois ennen oppituntia,
sen on eduskunta päättänyt.
Luottamuselinten kokouksissa kännykät laitetaan äänettömälle.
Miten on siis mahdollista, että kansanedustajat,
ja etenkin ministerit pääministeristä alkain räpläävät koko ajan kännyköitään,
eivätkä keskity kuuntelemaan käytävää keskustelua?
Tuo on ihan naurettavaa ja ylimielistä käytöstä.
Eduskunnan salin tuulessa pitää kaikkien kännykät kerätä pois,
kun eivät kerran osaa kännykän käytön käyttämissääntöä.
Terveisin siis harmistunut kansalainen.
Kansaradio.
Ja, hyvää päivää, täällä on valkia koskelta, Hannu kahila koski.
Oikein hyvää päivää, valkia koskelta.
Ja, kiitos.
Tuotanoen, ku mä tuota, olen tässä, kamppailu, tässä aina elokuussa,
noiden banaalikärpästen kasvosi.
Niitä tulee aina elokuussa, ja huusallii, ja ne on tosi inhottavia.
No, mä oon aina sitten lykänny noita,
laittanu sellaisen kupiin, jossa on mehua,
ja siinä on hunaja, ja pikkunen tippa,
semmoista pesunestettä, että se vie sen pintajänteen pois,
ne hukkuu sinne.
Siiähän on tullu valtavasta.
Mut sit mä yhtäkkiä koktasin tässä yks päivättä.
Mitäs, jos mä kokeilin tota desifiointiainetta,
mitä meidän siivoja käyttää tässä,
ja mä laitali keittiön roskatynnyriin,
siltikun sieltähän ne aina tulevat sieltä,
keittiöntekä roskaämpäristä.
Ni, mä oon ku olla huomannut,
Nyt meillä jo yhtään noitti kulen repun selkään,
ja lähti, ettei täällä voi olla.
Yhtäkkiä mä tajuisin,
että tää tyttöhän on tuonut meille ratkaisun tähän asiaan.
Täydellistä.
Onko sulla ollut tämmöistä ongelmaa?
Ä, tota, ei, minulla on vaan niitä sokeritoukkia,
mutta kun se on mun kissan lempi harrastus,
jahdatan niitä,
nii mä en niistä viti hankkiutua eroa.
Ja, sanotko vielä, että siis kuinka paljon laitat sitä desinfioittiainet?
Tait sitä?
No, en minä se roskaämpäriin koskaan laitat sitä kuin kolmis suihkausta.
Okei.
Ja siihen kantee sitten kyllä tietenkin,
koska mä kerran huomasin,
siihen oli tehneet jälkiläisille oltia ison katraja.
Okei.
Ja siitä ni tässä aina kuoriutu iltasia.
Ja, jolloinkin. Toisella ihmisellä voisi olla vielä parempia ideoita tähän.
Nii, voi vielä jättää vinkkiä, Nixi, mikä sinulla toiminut,
mutta voisitte vielä kysyä muilta, että minkälaisia vastaavia kikkoja muilla on,
banaanikärpästen kanssa.
Ja, joo, terveisiä, täältä valkia koskeltaa, ihana kaupunki,
sitä on valtava, valtava, kaunis kaupunki, kesällä varsinkin.
Joo.
Mutta oikein, oikein hyvää, kesää, kaikkea hyvää.
Hei, kiitos sitä samaa.
Ja, hei.
Moi.
Mikähän on tämän kotihoidon tarkoitus tänä päivänä?
Kun ei mitään muuta kuin viis minuuttia tuossa istutaan ja räplätään puhelintaan,
ja kun pyytää jotain, palvelutaan, ei minä nyt kerkeä, kun minä päivytän tämän.
Mikä tällä on tarkoitus?
Palvellaanko ihmisiä oikein?
Vai onko vaan kännykkä juttuja, että sinne vaan laitetaan jotakin tietoja.
Mutta ihmisestä ei välitetä yhtään mitään.
Että mikähän tässä on tarkoituksena?
Onko pirha vai kuka, joka kerää kovasti vaan rahoja siitä,
että joku vaan päivittää puhelimeen.
Ja sitten tarvitsi, jos tämmöstä täytyy tehdä,
tarvitsi laittaa konekiertoskursseille nää,
että ne saa nopeammin sitten nää laitettua.
Et ei tossa istuta niin kauvaa, mun tielläni.
Kiitos näkemii.
Täällä on kuuntelija.
Ostin, olohousut, ja valitettavasti, vaikka ne on esipestu,
niin valkonen nahkatuaali on aivan musta.
Siinä on isot mustat jäljet pepukohdalla ja jalkojen kohdalla,
ja kaikkein kamalinta on, että ne ei lähe pois vaikka yrittää pesuaineella,
että mitä ihmettä, eikä ne ollut mitkää halvat olohousut.
Mustat ne on, mutta en ymmärrä, mitä pitäis tehdä, kuinka kaikki värjäntyy.
Ja jos meillä olis jotain kauniita kangastuolia tai jotain,
ne olis ihan pilalle, ja kyllähän tämäkin on mennyt pilalle, tää nahkatuoli.
Kuinkani saa myydä tämmösiä huusuja?
Ja mitä pitäis tehdä, kun ei aina jaksais viedä takasi?
Mutta mä oon pettyny.
Kiitos vaan, valittaa sain.
Täällä Lappeenrannasta soittelee kansan radio vankkomaton kuuntelija.
Kyllä, tänä kesänä on kumma juttu, kun kiertelee retkipaikkoja ja retkisatamia,
niin miten sinne saapuu semmoisia saaren omistajia,
että kukaan ei osaa lämmittää?
Saunaa oikeinlaisilla puilla, oikeinlailla pilkotuilla puilla.
Ne tulee tosia yleisii, retkipaikkoihin ku maa omistajat.
Vaikka varmasti ovatkin vakkarikävijöitä, mutta pitäis silti ajatella,
että eläjä anna muittenki elää kesällä, eläkä tule sinne urputtamaan ku toiset on lomaansa viettämässä.
Kiitos ja hyvää kesää kaikille.
Kansan radio.
No, tässä on Lotta ja Elvi. Soitellaan täältä Hirvensalmen kupeesta.
Tervehdys, mitä kuuluu tänä sunnultaan?
No, oikein hyvä kuuluu. Soitellaan tästä Hirvensalmen kupeesta Etuniemen karavaan alueelta,
ja iskaskellaan tästä matkailuautosta ja kuunneltiin kansanradiota ja katsellaan ku sader oppisee ikkunaa.
Sitten alettiin semmoista pohtimaan, että ihmiset taitaa soittaa vain negatiivisia asioita sinne.
Ja sitten Elvi tässä kysyki, että eikö tonne saa soittaa mitään mukalaa?
Ehdottomasti, antaa tullu vaan.
Mitä, Elvi, sä keksit mukavia asioita, mitä meillä on ollut?
Kaikki on ilaisia, ja kaikki on aluliaita, ja pohteliaita, ja kaikki saunetta lämpimi, ja luonto on puhdasta, ja vesi on lämpi, ja puhdasta.
Ja, ei aina tarvi olla sitä, mitä haluaa, ja voi olla ystävien kanssa.
Nii.
No, siinähän on jo tosi iso määrä.
Nii, me keksyttiin helposti.
Joo.
Nystä me ajatteltiin, että me soitetaan ne, kun Elvi kysyi, että voiko tänne soittaa mukavia asioita,
niin me todettiin, että kyllä, sinne voi soittaa.
Ehdottomasti, risujen lisäksi myös ruusuja otetaan vastaan, totta kai.
Kyllä, nimenomaan välillä vähän ruusuja.
Joo, näin on, ja tällä hetkellä siellä sataa.
No, täällä sataa, mutta ei se meitä haittaa.
Ei, siis.
Se on kiva kuunnella sateeropinaa, ja pelata vähän pelejä.
Joo, jos pitäisi listata maailman kaikkein kivoimmat äänet, niin mä veikkaan, että sateeropina menee ihan top kolmose.
Ehdottomasti, kyllä.
Hei, minä kiitän todella paljon kumpaakin teitä, ku soititte.
Kiitoksia.
Mahti homma.
Joo.
Hei, mä toivotan teille hyvät päivät. Moikka.
Jessa, moi.
Moi, moi.
Ruusujakin otetaan oikein mielellä vastaan kansan radiossa, minä sitten ne yhteystiedot tuolla aikalopussa luettelen.
Nyt seuraavaksi siirrytään tien päälle, ja vähän vedenkin.
Paljon autoileva, nimimerkillä on tullut meille viesti, että minua kiinnostaa tietää.
Että mitkä on ne syyt, miksi henkilöautoilija päättää ajaa kesäkelissä, reilua alinopeutta.
No, sellaista asiaa, kun juttelin, juttelin yhden tutun kanssa, kuka viikonloppuisi, ja päivisin ajelee paljon tuolla öiseki aikaa kerää noita törkkiä, muuta niini.
Minäkin olen ihmetellyt sitä, että miten nää Voltin kuskit, ne saavat moottoripyörää, ajoneuvoa, ajaa ilman kypärää ja ilman valoja.
Ja tota, poliisit pitää kaikenlaisia ratsioita niini.
Tätä nyt uskin julkaistaa, ku minuu varmaan pidetää niinkun rasistina, mut ihmettelee, ja tätä on, tätä on jatkunnu varmaan kohta jotain kymmenen vuotta, että ei muuta.
No, se on teidän ritari kaheksa kolme, päijät hämäestä, ku täällä langan päässä roikkuu.
Erästä suurta ajattelijaa lainatakseni. Alitehosilla tauduksilla revitää jäähallikkokoisia solifereja, ja paska haisee, ja kaasupullot paukkuu.
Ni, kyllä täytyy sanoa, että kyllä on matkailu vauhdut, mitä täällä kiskotaan, jouset pohjassa, ja koko suku takapenkillä, ja puolomaisuutta kyydissä, ja satasen rajoitus, ja kuuskytään viis hänit uski, jos se mittari näyttää ni.
Ei, herra, jubala, hei, ihmiset, teltta on ihan hyvä ratkaisu, ja se takamettä siinä tontirajan, tuolla puolen.
Et tää tota alinopeus, rajoituskäyttöä, ja teltta, hyvää kesää.
Minä kun täytin 71 vuotta, ja minä en ole enää oikeutettu autolla ajoon, koska ajokorttini ei ole enää voimassa, saanko ajaa mopoautolla?
Paikoinaan sai ajaa 15-vuotiaana mopoa, ilman minkälaista korttia. Mutta saako nykyään ajais mopoa? 71-vuotias ihminen, tä.
No, yksys, mä laiden tässä vaan. Sunnuntana, kansanradiossa joku nainen valitti, kuinka syysmä saumuka huono, tietiä, ja tota kauheesti montuja.
Sa olet mahtanu ajela täällä. Siis jossain vaiheessa, vuosia sitten, pari vuotta, kolme vuotta sitten, oli todella montuja, mut ei oo enää.
Ajelepa uudesta, ja katto silvilläs. Niii, ei ole mitään montuja, tääl on tieti ihan hyväs kunnossa.
Ja kunta kyllä huolehti, että voida tuona, paremmin kuin jossain muualla. Moi moi.
Niin, mä oon tässä joko ajan sitten muuttanut, imatolle ihmitellyt, ku, nyt ku tää Saiman kanava on tukossa.
Mikäntäkin nää, Suomessa on kaiken muama hölmäjä, muitakin tehty, muun muassa suunnitelaan tää kolme aurelta, mihin pannaan kuusi miljardia euroa, joka ois, nelitenkin Tampere Turku.
Nii.
Ni miksei, miksei, enää, tota, enää vaalimaita, ku loppuu tää kanavan Suomen puolenta, ni siitä, kanavan suoraan merellä.
Sit oi joko i oskus puhunu, ja totta, ku ajattelee, tää nykytilannetta, muutenkin, miten tänne tulee turisti ja kaikkee, ni mitä upee systeemi sais, ku sinne sais normaali matkustajalaivaa plus, tietysti rahtilaivat ja kaikki vuutsi.
Saiman kanava.
Nii, se, kato, Saiman kanava, ku lähtee tuossa Lapperaasta etelään päin, ni, enää, vaan tässä siihen sementti, tuoko, se ei ikinä oo, ohjittaa se kanava suoraa Virolahdelle tästä vaalimalta.
Yheskytki, vajaa yheskyt kilometrisillä järviä välissä ja kaikkea, saat mielettömän turistikohtaja.
Nyt, kun noin paahtuu ja palaa noin turistit tonne Keski-Eurooppaa, nehän suutaa tänne.
Nii.
Mussi, että siit sais koko tän Itä-Suomen, isojen kaupunkien, teolisuuden, tosi edulisen kulitusmuodon, sitä kautta suoraan tonne Euroopan, Euroopan maihin.
Koit kattaisimmis Euroopassa, ni, Amsterdamista pääset viiniin jokilaittojen pit, jokilaivoilla, ja ne on mielettömän suosittuja.
Ai, se, emma nois kyllä hieno resu, kertakaitki.
Nii, se on tosi makkeen, tuota mooselin kautta, sun muoto, ne on ojan.
Ootko käyny jo?
E, no, mut mä oon niitä nähny, ku syöny siellä Euroopassa, nii, vaan oon nähny niitä isoja jokilaivoja ja kaikkea, ni.
Tommaseen pitäis panna fyrkkaa, eikä mihkää, älyttömiä kolmio ratoi.
Nii just, eli siitä vaan rajaa pitkin, melkeimpä, melkeimpä.
Nii, nii, ja vähän koukkaamaan, sinne on semmoisi järviä välistä, mitkä pystii ohituspaikkona,
ja sillä ku laivat tulevat vastaakaan, ni siitä tuli tosi fiksu juttu,
en usko, etta pinta tarvii, hemmeti, monta estäitä, kantnota sulkuja sinne.
En sanonut, etta oli yllättävä ehdotus, en olis osannut veikata.
Nii, ku Euroopastakin tulee jängitä, lentokonnolle, Suomee.
Nee, lentää vaikka Helsinkiä, siitä laivalla, kolme viikon ristilinen,
kuinka paljon sitä ois syrkkaa tonne, joka puole.
Ai, mieti, mieti sitä, paitsi kesällä ku menee suomalaisen metsämaiseman läpi,
niin onhan se nyt.
Tämmönen kesä ku nytki olleet, viittyjäkön, kaskemeta lämmitä,
ne eurooppalaiset jonottaa tänne.
Nyt minä haluan, nyt minä haluan tämä.
Ostetaan laiva.
Hei, kiitos paljon ku soitit.
Päivä jatkot.
Miten ihminen voi olla pelkkä nolla?
Tällaisella nimimerkillä saapunut viesti, jossa lukee, että edellisessä kansanradiossa Olkinuora totesi,
että vaikka nuoret sukupolvet on monesti väitetysti olleet pilalla,
niin nii heistä vaan kasvaa sivistyneitä aikuisia aikanaan.
Näin ei vaikuttaisi kumminkaan olevan.
Tämänhetken aikuiset, joilla pieniä lapsia, ovat niitä NS vapaan kasvatuksen saaneita.
Käytännössä heitä, joilta puuttuu hyvät tavat järki ja vastuullisuus.
Tuossa iltapäivälehdessäkin oli hiljattain juttua kotieläintilojen vierailijoista, jotka häiriköivät eläimiä, heittelevät kiviä niiden päälle ja ties mitä.
Tässä toiminnassa on mukana kurittomat kakarat vanhempineen.
Ei muuta kuin porttikielto näilee ja kuvat julkisuuteen, jos aikuinen toimii näin, niin hänellä ei ole kaikki kotosalla, ja siitä kärsii ajan kanssa muutkin.
Vapaa kasvatus luo pelkkää ongelmaa, ja se kertaantuu sukupolvesta toiseen.
Hei, tuu täältä Etelä-Suomesta tervehdys.
Me oon alkanu huolestuttaa.
Ensimmäistä kertaa oikeastaan kunnolla tämä yhteiskunnan tilaa, missä me eleetää ja asuta.
Ei tämä enää tunnu siltä Suomelta, jonka mä oon tuntenu, ja jonka vaikutuspiirissä sitä o saanu kasvaa.
Mite se näkyy, niin se näkyy, että ihmisillä o alkanu olla pahaa olla.
Osa putoaa yhteiskunnan kelkasta, se näkee tuolla kaduilla ja kaupungilla ku liikkuu.
Semmonen pelon ilmapiiri on vallanu ihmiset, ja siinä on taustalla ihan selvästi semmoinen taloudellinen ahdinko, mihin tämä politiikka on ajanu meitä, suomalaisia, etenkin vähävaraisia.
Mikä itsestä tuntuu pahalta, on tuo härskius, millä tavalla täällä yhteiskunnassa puhutaan, vaikkapa nyt tosi heikossa asemassa olevista.
Sosa taannoin tuli median kautta esille muun muassa, että palautuspullojen keräijää vihjailtiin, että ne on veronalaista tuloa.
Osa ihmisistä kerää henkesä pitimiksi noita tonkii tuolla roskakoreja, että saa jotakin suuhun pantavaa.
Sitten kehdataan vielä alkaa puhuma, että maksakaa niistä verot.
Härskiydellä ei oo mitään rajaa enää tässä yhteiskunnassa.
Itestä tuntuu, että pitäisi jonkun alkaa puhaltaa peli poikki ja alkaa rakentaa tätä maata ihan nykyiseltä alusta asti uudelleen, semmoiseksi mitä tämä on ollut aikaisemmin.
Suunta on nyt semmoinen, että täällähän pärjää pääasiassa tuommoiset sijoittajat ja erittäin rikkaat pohdat, joilla ei oo huolei häivää elämästä.
Omassa elämässä tämä on vaikuttanut siihen, että, jos tuotani terveyskeskusmaksut alkaa kasaantua, niitä on laittanut tuonne hyvinvointialueen tämmöiseen järjestelmään, missä niitä pitäisi niinkön puolittaa tai kohtuullistaa.
Sieltä tuli hylkäävä päätös, ajat on koventunut selvästi sielläkin.
Tämä on tyyppisiä asioita, turha haaveilla, myöskään mistää linnanmäkireissusta ja vastaavista.
Jotain pitäis tehdä, kuki tietäs miten lähtee rakentamaan. Kuki omalla panouksella tietenki. Kiitos, hei.
Haluaisin ottaa kantaa ruokan ja ruokailu hoitokodissa. Minulla on omainen hoitokodissa, olen jo pitkän aikaa seurannut omaiselleni ja muillekin vannoksille tarvattava ruokaa.
Liiän samanlaista mautonta tai liian mausteista ruokaa. Eihän se kenellekin maistu, ei ainakaan vannoksille.
Olen vienyt omaiselleni joskus puu ruotavelli, tai mitä nyt maistuu, ja sä syöidäkseen.
Vannoksit ovat tottuneet ruokan, ihan perusruokan. Mutta kun ruokien valmistustapahtuu muualla, ei saida niin sanottu kontrolli pelata.
Kun ajatellaan, että mitä tämä niinkutsutu ruokka maksaa, ei voi kun ihmetellä, mistä oikein maksutaan.
Se on hyviäkin hoitokotia, jossa ruokailla tehdään paikan päällä. Tuntuu, että elämänsä ehtopuolella olevat ihmiset ei tiedä, mitä on tapahtunut. Ei todella ole oikein.
Jalkapallon MM on nyt MM mäilty.Sitten ei muuta kuin odottamaan vuorossa 2028 on jalkapallon Euroopan mestaruuskilpailut.
Ehkä sitä silmällä pitäen tämä tarjalta saapunut viesti, joka on otsikoitu, että hybridiselostusta.
Nyt kun jalkapallon MM-kisojen aikaan lähetykset tulivat illalla ja yöllä, ja ainoastaan televisiosta, niin se oli harmittavaa.
Radioselostukset olivat aikoinaan mökkikesän suola.
On paljon ihmisiä, jotka siinä työnsä ohessa kuuntelevat, katselevat lähetyksiä.
Sama tilanne on valioliiga ja mestarien liigan lähetysten kanssa.
Kenelläkään ei ole aikaa tai mahdollisuutta istua koko ajan TV:n ääressä.
Siksi selostajien tulisi opetella NS-hybridiselostusta, tavallaan selostaa, kuten TV:ssä,
mutta samalla huomioida ne ihmiset, jotka vain kuuntelevat, ja välillä katsovat, kun aikaa on.
Monotoninen pelaajien nimien toistelu tai tilastojen luettelointi ei anna käsitystä, että mitä kentällä tapahtuu, ja missä pelin painopiste kulloinkin on.
Siksipä pitäisi selostaa niin, että Messi nousee vasenta laitaa, harhauttaa, keskittää boksin ja Alvarez puskee maalin, eikä niin, että Messi, Messi, Messi, Alvarez, maali.
Tällainen kehitysehdotus tuli siis Tarelta.
Ei huolta nämä nii sanoltut uutiset, kun tulloa joka tunnin piasta, Radio Suomessa.
Ne luetää niinku juosten kustuna, luetää nii nopeisti, ja sitten taas seuraava tunti, sama peli, seuraava tunti, sama peli.
Miks ne ei voi olla reilummita? Sii ei, jos kerran uutisia riittää, nii, ei ku katu tätä netistä, ja katu vaikka mista bluetubista, mut eihän vanhukset.
Telainen arkat kerkii, eikä suuri osavanukset ei kerki, tää riittää. Ei mulle molluta, kiitos.
Täälo, Markus, taas naantalista nais, des teko naurus, on des, televisio ja radiosuami.
Varsinkin naisihime, siel on kamalaa käkätystä, eik se moist ois vähä vähentää, ku ei mitkä nauratanu.
Tääntää mikään iloinen, hirveitä kuunneltavaa, morjes.
No hei, en oo enää itse, koulujessa, muta ihmeetyttää nii suuresti, ku heinäkuun puolivälin paikkeilla alkaa tulla jo mainoksia koulujen alusta.
Voi härrekuut, muta hyvää sunnuntaita kaikille, ja kesä jatkuu, oi.
Kansaradio.
Joo, kulit täältä, Pohjanmaalta, tämä, yks akka, mä tienitin huomiota siihen, ku sinne joku nainen tuota, kritisoi tätä laulua, tätä, tätä pitää, tää Mariska laulaa, tätä suloinen myrkykeittejä.
Sulonen myrkykeittejä, joo.
Joo, nii, että, sen pitäis kieltää, mä oon kyllä samaa mieltä.
Koska, koska, eijä sinne laulee se oo mitään vikaa, se oo ihan hyvää laulee, tää Mariska, mutta niinku, tämä, tämä sanoma, mitä sinne laulus on.
Ja, että sinne keutetaan, tai niinku nainen suunnittelee murhaavan, pyrkittävän, saman miehen, jotta hän se oo rakastajan kanssa jonkun riio.
Että, mitenkäs sitten, jos olis, päinvastoin olis ollut, että joku miesartisti olis saman levittänyt, siinä olis varmaan huuret, naisviarteja, kaikista muusta.
Jotta, kun kuuntelee esimerkiksi, tuure tilpeläisen, sitä hyvä paha roma mies, ei parempaa laulua voi suomalaiselle miehelle tehdä, kun se tuuren kappale on.
Mutta justiin tämä, että, kun nainen kehottaa, valmistaa myrkyy, jotta saa hengimmänoi, heti tuottaa, ja äijä saa sen maistaa, niin mun mielestä, tällaiset kappaleet pitäis kieltää.
Sitä mieleen, siitä suloinen myrkykeittäjä kappalesta, se vie minut sellaisee, jos silmät sulkee, niin näkee jonkun mustavalkoisen vanhan murhamysteerin, tai jonkun vastaavan.
Et se tuntuu vähän sellaiselta elokuvamaiselta tarinalta.
On paljon tällaisen, että on jotakin mielenterveisongelmiäkin, niin voi helposti ajatella, että jotä laulokehoutta.
Mutta mihin sitten vedetään se raja, ettei mitä uskaltaa sanoa, koska joku saattaa jossain käsittää sen väärin?
Ni sekin on vähän haastava.
Joo, se on justiin tämä, mutta tämä, että ku...
Niin kuin mä sitten oi sanonut, että jos olisi ollut päiväistaan, että mies olisi, että lähtiä rakastaa perisekkaa siioo, niin siitä olisi ollut kauheaa haloo, että naisvihasta.
Joo, ja hyvä kesänjatkoa suullekin.
Hei, kiitoksia, ku soitit tänne, kesänjatkoja.
Joo.
Joo, moi.
Joo, hei.
Lopuksi nostetaan vielä esiin muutamat asiat, joihin soittajien mielestä ehdottomasti pitäisi kiinnittää huomiota, sitä ennen minä luettelen yhteystietoja.
Esimerkiksi meidän sähköposti, se on kansan.radio at yle.fi.
Kirjepostia, jos haluat laittaa, niin kansanradio PL 79 000 24, Yleisradio.
Oikea WhatsApp-numero on 044 55 154 64, ja sitten se vastaajan numero, se on 08 00 154 64.
Siinä siis kansanradion yhteystiedot, jokainen on tervetullut laittamaan viestiä, välittämään mielipiteensä tämän ohjelman kautta.
Jos on vaikka tehnyt ihminen yhden parhaimmista sijoituksista, jonka ihminen voi tehdä ja hankkinut itselleen, riippukeinun,
siinä köllätellessä juolahtaa mieleensä yksi asia, joka on ruvennut ihmetyttämään erityisen paljon.
Etta on se kumma, kun tähän asiaan ei kiinnitetä huomiota, niin ei ku vaan kansanradio viestiä.
Lasse Olkinoara toivottaa oikein hyvää juuri tätä hetkeä, liittyy siihen sitten riippukeinu kuinka paljon tahansa.
No joo, Pekka vaan soittelee.
Suomalainen potkupalloilu on kielettävä lailla, Suomen eduskunnan ja hallituksen yhteisellä päätöksellä.
Nyt kun on käynnissä jalkapallon maalimammestaruuskilpailut, se on jalkapalloa, mutta Suomessa pelataan potkupalloa.
Kiitoksia ja piste.
Jäällä tätä sysmästä hyvää päivää, mutta sano, kertoisi semmoista juttua tässä, kun kauppujen hinnat nousee jatkuvasti, mutta eläkkeet ei nouse.
Tai minkä on syy, pitää eläkkeekin nousta yhtälää, kun ruuahinta nousee, ei muuta kiitos.
Täällä Jussi, Jyväskylästä, teltoja vallataan, aurinkopaneeleilla.
Mulla olis semmoinen mielikua, että ne, vois ne aurinkopaneelit tehdään niinkun joulukuusemallisia sen samaan pello reunoille.
Sitten niihin jääs, kato sinne keskelle jääs, viljelijälle sitten, vaikka rehu, heinän, viljelyä tai mitää vaan.
Mutta kussani on aurinkoinen paikka, ni siihen reunoja kiertämään ne joulukuuset.
Ja toinen olis semmoinen, et se ku voimalaitokset sinne alajuoksu, sehah on kesätalvet sula, ni siihen vois laittaa semmoisia siipirattaita, mitkä pyörii, vaikka ei tuulekkaani.
Nä ei oo niinkun, ne oo tuulivapaat.
Ei muuta, hei.
Sanoisin vaan näille kaapuntilaisille, kun meette maaseudulle, ja jos tulee pissahätä, ja meette pellon reunaan, ni tuota, kattokaa, ettei siinä oo sähtöpaimenta.
Kun pissitte, muute voet saada, kikkelio rullalle, täh, hä hä.